bruno daroux un mode de déclaration
qu'on a entendu tout à l'heure vladimir
poutine qui propose des négociations en
biélorussie les ukrainiennes ne sont pas
contre la négociation mais pas en
biélorussie puisque la biélorusse sont
coupables de participer à cette guerre
est ce que c'est un pas faire la
diplomatie ou un jeu de dupes
à écouter on peut dire quand même c'est
plutôt un jeu de dupes à l'heure qu'il
est car d'une part effectivement moscou
en proposant que des négociations aient
lieu en biélorussie c'est très bien que
les ukrainiens ne peuvent pas accepter
un tel endroit le président hélène ce
qui a d'ailleurs répété qu'il avait
proposées on l'a vu là dans l'extrait
tout à l'heure plusieurs vilains
varsovie budapest
lavabre à part cela va istanbul donc en
fait ce que demande et les ukrainiens
c'est sur le principe oui à des
négociations mais dans un lieu neutre en
quelque sorte qui n'est pas du tout
impliqué dans le conflit ce qui n'est
pas le cas de la biélorussie et puis
après oui à des négociations mais dans
quelles conditions et pour faire quoi
faire que les ukrainiens ne veulent pas
sans doute même s'ils ne le disent pas
ça officiellement mais ils ne veulent
pas de négocier en position de faiblesse
vis-à-vis de vladimir poutine parce que
ils connaissent l'animal si vous me
passez l'expression savent très bien que
vladimir poutine va où il négocie avec
eux mais avec un pistolet sur la tempe
en quelque sorte alors disant écoutez
voilà vous voyez dans quelle situation
vous êtes donc soit vous acceptez ça ça
ça et ça
soit les négociations s'arrête quoi donc
les ukrainiens eux ils veulent alors
aidé parce qu'ils appellent maintenant
la coalition internationale par l'europe
etc ils veulent négocier mais sur une
base plus égalitaire et en tout cas ni
pour dégager le régime politique de
zelensky ni pour démilitariser l'arménie
pour
revenir sur leur intégrité territoriale
ou leur souveraineté peut-être y avoir
des négociations sur l'adhésion à l'otan
mais est encore mais ce sera tout quoi
donc voyez que le coeur de ce qui ferait
les négociations et très compliqué parce
que c'est si négociations il y a elle
démarrait sur de très mauvaises bases
dans l'état actuel des choses oui parce
que forcément telle qu'on connaît
vladimir poutine il va y aller en
pensant qu'il est en position de force
donc évidemment il va proposer voilà une
de ces solutions soient soit une une
partition soit une annexion
définitive du donbass ou de la crimée
soit l'installation d'un autre
gouvernement à kiev et tout ça
franchement évidemment n'est pas
acceptable pour le président zelensky